I just want to thank foreign spark for
making this great facility available to
us we've had a number of our meetings
throughout the year here at some of your
fabulous restaurants as well and the
service is just outstanding the food is
great the staff is so cooperative and
it's a it's just a pleasure to be at
Maureen's Park so right now I'm gonna
introduce our moderator who indeed will
introduce the panelists
he's dr. hiranya Raja Singh and has a
he's a vascular surgeon here in Naples
and a 1988 graduate of the Yale Medical
School dr. ah thank you good afternoon I
have the distinct honor of introducing
our panel today and again dr. Mary
Chinetti who was to give the first
lecture thank you was is not able to be
here due to other reasons but doctor the
okuni will give his/her talk so in order
let me just introduce our distinguished
panel dr. Kennedy is the Gladys Phillips
Crawford professor of medicine in
geriatrics at public health as is the
chief of geriatrics at the Yale School
of Medicine dr. 10 dr. Judy sure doctor
tonight was the first investigator to
show that older adults could reduce
their risk of Falls and fall injuries
does avoiding one of the major
contributors to functional disabilities
their current research focused is on the
net benefit and harms of commonly used
medications for older adults in the face
of multiple health conditions she's also
a leading national effort leading a
national effort to develop and text an
approach through healthcare
decision-making that focuses on the
individual health priorities of older
adults with multiple conditions she
chairs a group of advisors helping a
large large health systems becoming age
friendly
Tonetta has published over 250 articles
she has received numerous awards and is
a member of the National Academy of
Medicine and the MacArthur Foundation
fellow dr. Leo Cooney to my left is the
Humana foundation professor geriatric
medicine at Yale University School of
Medicine dr. Cooney established the
program in geriatrics at Yale in 1976
and served as chief of sectional
geriatric internal medicine at Yale as
well as the chief of sectional
geriatrics
he was the president's of the president
of the medical staff of Yale New Haven
Hospital and his past president of the
American geriatric Society
dr. Cooney has won multiple teaching
awards from Yale medical residents and
students his research and teaching
activities have been focused on
assisting elderly individuals attain the
highest level of independence possible
he is committed to ensuring that
resident physicians and students at Yale
are as prepared as possible to care for
elderly patients immediately oh so she's
now go skip over to Brianne minor doctor
minor is a geriatrician and sleep
medicine physician and researcher
interested in improving the management
of sleep-wake symptoms in older adults
after receiving her medical degree from
the State University of New York
downstate medical center she completed
further training at yale university
specifically residency in internal
medicine and a clinical and research
fellowship in geriatrics and a clinical
fellowship in sleep medicine her current
interests include investigation of
insomnia symptoms and daytime sleepiness
in older adults as these are prevalent
and likely to have adverse effects on
important health-related outcomes
ultimately she aims to design
interventions for symptoms of insomnia
and daytime sleepiness in older persons
with within without cognitive impairment
which may lead to improvements in
cognitive and physical function finally
our last speaker is dr. James Lai dr.
livesey associate chief of clinical
affairs for geriatrics at the
school medicine and overseas a vibrant
clinical program includes three skilled
nursing facilities for primary care
sites a home-based primary care program
an inpatient consultation service and
the Keystone Adler geriatric assessment
clinic is also co chief of the inpatient
Cooney firm service at the Center for
rest tripped of care at the Yale New
Haven Hospital at st. Raphael's campus
and serves on numerous system-wide
committees dedicated to quality
improvement and creating an age-friendly
health system NFL of ATS also fell of
Trumbull College on the undergraduate
campus as a graduate of Wake Forest
University School Medicine dr. live
trained in internal medicine at the
University of Maryland in Baltimore and
went on to a completer fellowship and
geriatrics and a clinical research
fellowship with the Robert Wood Johnson
clinical Scholars Program both at the
Yale University School of Medicine dr.
Eli brings a broad clinical experience
to Yale having practiced primary care in
the community for eight years followed
by four years exclusively as the
inpatient hospice and floor medical
director at the AL New Haven Hospital
currently he's focused on developing the
geriatrics program in Yale to meet the
clinical educational and research needs
of the institution and growing
population we will begin with the first
lecture that's going to be given by dr.
Cooney this is how to get what matters
most to you from your health care and he
will be doing that the second lecture
which is maintaining interdependence
independence gives me just we will have
the questions and answers taken at the
very end of all three speakers and I'll
be happy to help moderate that dr.
kameen thank you very much can everybody
hear me okay with the microphone it's
okay all right
so my claim to fame at Yale is that I
recruited married to Nettie and then I
capped married today and and that reason
that's so important is that Mary who won
a MacArthur Genius award for her work
and Falls was recruited to be deans of
schools and had
programs etc she stayed at Yale not cuz
of me she say that Yale predominantly
because she wanted to continue her
research he was so concerned about how
we care for older people so she's gone
from Falls which he continues to work in
to the problem of sort of patient
directed care so some of us collect
stamps others collect coins others
collect year old books but we all
collect as we age our diseases right you
basically get more conditions as you age
so the problem of caring for older
people is your caring for people with
multiple conditions and how to focus
your treatment on what the patient
really wants as opposed to the the
condition itself or the numbers if you
will no I'm gonna see if I can get this
to work okay so we're gonna start with a
patient that was part of Mary's study
mr. Smith and we're gonna go by the
numbers he's 77 as three children five
grandchildren one wife has six chronic
diseases arthritis of his hip diabetes
hypertension etc he's on nine
medications he has five doctors and
that's a challenge how those doctors and
interact with each other big part oh
we're gonna talk about today and he
actually has two health visits a week
but I mean by health is it not
necessarily a doctor's visit but going
to a laboratory or getting a variety of
tests done so a lot of his life is
focused on that and his doctors are
always telling his blood pressure is too
high
his glucose has to do with too high and
they're concerned about his conditions
and his orthopedic surgeon says your hip
x-ray is bad you need a hip replacement
but he's not sure about that his real
complaint is he's tired all the time he
can't do what he wants to do because
he's so fatigued he thinks he spends too
much time on his healthcare and he's not
sure about this idea of surgery so
health care for persons with multiple
conditions it's a challenging because
our our ability to benefit people with
multiple conditions is not that clear
most research
is done on patients with one condition
or is focused on that one condition not
the six seven or eight conditions that
so many older people have now the care
can be burdensome it may not focus on
what matters most to the patient so what
do we do well our answer a mary's answer
is find out what matters most and let
your clinicians know about that what's
most important to you but that's not so
quite so easy it takes some challenging
when we look at older people ask them
what's most important to them health
care is not huge it's about twenty five
percent of people are concerned about
living longer about a third of people
want their symptoms relieved but almost
half of people focus on their function
their independence their ability to care
for themselves it's appropriately very
important to those individuals so when
identifying health priorities mary's
looked at a lot of different areas she
looked at connecting and that is with
family friends community or church or
synagogue enjoying life your
productivity recreation personal growth
your function your dignity and
independence and also maintaining your
health and managing your symptoms so as
she's tried to do that she's focusing on
goals what's most important to the older
individual and I'm looking at those
goals they have to be goals we can take
action with they have to be goals that
are consistent and reliable but they
also have to be realistic
so what are the important goals that may
be babysitting and playing with a
grandchild it may be working
half day and doctor's visit interfere
with that it may be working doing
ceramics or walking half a mile but that
can be difficult because they might be
so fatigued and that may you know impede
their ability to do what they want to do
alright
so as we look at health care what is it
involved in involves taking pills it
involves going into visits to devolve
some testing and procedures and so we
call self-management activities that is
about fulfilling the exercise program or
dietary program that clinicians might
ask you to do oh and
Mary asked different patients about this
in her studies they might get the answer
I get blood tests done every month
that's not bad
CPAP which is continuous positive airway
pressure it's a treatment to use for
patients that have what's called sleep
apnea sometimes helps it's quite
burdensome though okay
the patient may tell you they walk and
do their exercises and that medication
does help their acid reflux okay but
just as commonly if not more commonly
what the patient tells you is that that
burdened by their healthcare their
medications cause muscle pain and it's
hard to be active their sugars are too
tightly controlled with their diabetes
so they get low blood sugars so called
hypoglycemia and shaking they have to
check their insulin and glucose too
often and then I want surgery all right
so it's a little more complicated so
what we're trying to do is align care
with what patients really want all right
so how do we do that well first thing is
to start with one thing so we're getting
back to mr. Smith his major concern was
not as blood pressure or as diabetes or
his hip arthritis was the fact that he
was tired all the time
he was fatigued that was his major
symptom that's what really bothered him
all right so then we need to look at
what can we do to deal with that fatigue
it might be discontinuing some
medications might be changing
medications it might be looking for a
medical cause of that but we want to
focus on that symptom that is most
important to the patient we want to use
that patients priority not so much their
diseases in decision-making and
assessing benefit we want to focus on
desired activity so what's the activity
that mr. Smith wants he wants to be able
to go to his club three times a week and
he can't do it now he's too fatigued he
has to nap all day that's his major
complaint now in dealing with that we
have to deal with American medicine in
2019 and that is the number of sub
specialists or specialists that so many
patients have collaborating with those
people inter communicating with those
individuals to try to come up with
approaches is very very important one
study showed that when you go to see a
cardiologist for the first time you walk
out with five prescriptions so that's a
big challenge and we know that multiple
medications causes a lot of problems the
primary care physician very often has to
do a little discussion and negotiating
with the specialist when trying to alter
the medication that the patient is
taking so these collaborative
negotiations we have to agree on what
information is important we have to also
agree that there's no right answer and
get together in brainstorm a little bit
about alternatives getting back to mr.
Smith again he wants to be left tired he
wants to get to his club a few days a
week his medications make him too tired
so his healthcare outcome goal is to get
to the club three times a week his
preferences are to decrease his
medications and to avoid surgery so in
Mary's program she worked with a primary
care physician and the cardiologist were
able to decrease medications with the
end result the patient was less tired
and was able to get to the club working
with the orthopedic surgeon it became
clear that the decision to operate on
the hip should not be on the basis of
the x-ray or MRI of the hip it should be
on the symptoms the patient has and the
impact those symptoms have on that
person's activity and lifestyle so Mary
went ahead into the study she actually
used a group of physicians who were not
affiliated with Yale and in fact they
were affiliated with Yale's competitor
and that is the Hartford healthcare
system a group called pro health and
they were in a town called Bristol
Connecticut now some of you may Bristol
was outside Hartford about 40 years ago
a fellow named dick Rasmussen decided
that he would experiment with the idea
of doing 24 hours sports programming so
we established it was called the Easton
professional sports Network you may know
what is ESPN and and now when you go to
Bristol Connecticut that's all you see
is the SPN my sister is actually an
associate as an executive producer with
them so I know a little bit about it but
in any event it happened that the group
that Mary was working with was
bristle and she had ten primary care
physicians again these are all
physicians associated with one health
care system what's called pro health so
with ten primary care physicians five
cardiologists 163 patients and as in all
medical experiments neither control
group so the usual care group was seven
primary care physicians and 203 patients
so what were the results of that study
well there was more focused on patients
goals that's pretty obvious but really
importantly what happened was 42% of the
patients who were participating in this
goal directed care were able to decrease
medications as opposed to 24% in the
control group ten percent were able to
avoid procedures versus five percent in
the control group and there was a
significant decrease in what's called
treatment burden in the experimental
group so basically what mary has
demonstrated in this study was that
focusing on patient goals getting a
collaborative relationship between
primary care physicians and specialists
you can make a difference so you're
focusing not so much in the numbers of
the blood pressure of the diabetes
you're focusing on what's important to
the patient so what are the next steps
Mary is working on doing studies in more
areas and spreading to healthcare
systems and teaching students and
resident physicians more at Yale and
elsewhere about sort of patient directed
care when James talks to you later
about the health associated health
systems health friendly health system
you're going to hear about the 5ms and
one of them is what matters most so it's
really important as clinicians that we
learn what is most important to our
patient and focus on those goals as
opposed to the abstract numbers that we
deal with often in the practice of
medicine I'm going to stop there again
we're going to do questions at the end
and slip over to my talk all right so
you you heard and you saw that when Mary
looked at what was so important to older
people function was the most important
thing so we wanna make
maintain our independence we want to be
able to care for ourselves what can we
do about that how can we try to ensure
that we stay as independent as possible
so when talking about independence one
of the major focuses of independence is
mobility that is getting around alright
so as you're thinking about maintaining
your independence I would recommend one
thing that you listen to your body that
you pay attention when you start to have
problems with your mobility and if you
have a problem what component of
mobility might be the problem and what
might be the cause of that component of
mobility and how might it be corrected
so what do I mean by components of
mobility what I mean is what are those
things we have to do every day to get
through the day we gotta get our bed
first okay so you have to get out of bed
you have to be able to get off a chair
or off a toilet very importantly walking
in a safe environment without Falls is
very very important obviously and then
if you live in New Haven you have to
learn about climbing stairs perhaps in
fort myers and naples is less of an
issue but stair climbing is a major
issue with older people and particularly
it's an area where Falls do occur so
interesting Neil Alexander did a study
about 30 years ago Michigan so when you
look at younger people when they're
going from lying to sitting what we call
supine to sitting they don't use their
arms if you look at older people people
above the age of 70 when they're going
from lying the sitting they use their
arms to do that so if an older person
has a shoulder fracture has a rotator
cuff tear has arthritis of the wrist
elbow or shoulder they may find it
difficult to get out of bed so what do
you do in those circumstances obviously
you try to work on the shoulder fracture
and the arthritis and those things but
you do a very simple thing you go to
your surgical supply store you go online
and you purchase a hand bedrail it cost
about 50 bucks you slide it between the
mattress and the boxspring makes a huge
difference in your ability to get in
to bed should you have problems with one
of your upper extremities getting up
from a chair is extraordinarily
important individuals in wheelchairs can
live a very independent existence if
they can get from that chair to a toilet
by themselves from that chair to another
chair by themselves so we use the word
transferring when we're talking about
getting in and out of a chair so you may
see some older people I'm gonna put the
microphone down just for a second
all that a momentum transfer and it
tells us that that individual has some
trouble with usually their lower
extremities if they need to do that to
get up off a chair most of us get off a
chair with a stabilizing what's called a
momentum technique and what do we mean
by that well I'm sorry this is a rapid
the momentum technique there okay so
normally in a stabilizing technique you
simply move to the edge of the chair you
position your feet in the proper place
and then you use two muscle groups you
use your quadriceps muscle and your
quadriceps muscle is that thigh muscle
which extends your knee use your gluteus
maximus muscle to extend your hip to go
from a sitting to a standing position I
don't mean to be so anatomic here but
it's important to understand this when
we try to fix problems if people are
having this so basically you start
sitting you extend your knee and you
extend your hip in order to stand up
okay chairs are a big issue and you're
probably aware that there are some
things you want to avoid in terms of
chairs you want to avoid sitting in the
middle of the couch you want to avoid
low heavily cushioned chairs and you
definitely want to avoid chairs on
wheels okay so you want a solid chair
you want to chair with arms and you want
it to be roughly 20 inches high because
if it's too low it's more difficult to
get out of you know that when you get up
from a regular toilet that can be
problematic so we have ways of dealing
with that but it's very important that
you understand the difficulty you might
be having if you're having trouble
getting from a sitting to a standing
position so what are some of those
things that are going to impair your
ability to get off a chair weakness that
we call the proximal muscles your
quadriceps muscle and your gluteus
maximus muscle those are the two muscles
that extend your knee and extend your
hip knee problems huge issues in terms
of getting off a chair so knee
immobility or pain can limit your
ability to get off a chair
disease can also affect your ability to
get off a chair of toilet and sometimes
you have you have low back pain or
sciatica that can affect it too because
when you straighten all the way up that
will sometimes exacerbate the symptoms
you're having of your lower back or your
sciatica and that can also impair your
ability to stand so what do we do if we
see somebody and we evaluate that person
and determine that the trouble is with
doing a transfer that is sitting to
standing we try and decide what's the
limiting factor so if the limiting
factor is quadricep strength will start
quadricep strengthening exercises and
one is your handouts you do very simple
quadricep strengthening exercises if you
have hip disease we might treat that
with a steroid injection or surgery
physical therapy actually doesn't help
hip disease helps knee disease a lot but
it doesn't do much for hip disease for
knee disease we have injections physical
therapy surgery
balance exercises we'll talk more about
that when we talk about gait and
treatment of back pain and sciatica are
all steps we can take if people have
trouble with getting on off and on a
chair huge issue as you get a bit older
turn to Emily Dickinson now I step from
plank to plank so slow and cautiously
the Stars about my head I felt about my
feet to see I knew not but the next
would be my final inch this gave me that
precarious gait some call experience so
we're gonna talk about gait it's a big
issue and I want to talk a little bit
again can you all hear me as I'm moving
along here okay so we don't think an
awful lot about how we walk but I'm
gonna take a couple of minutes to go
through sort of in slow motion what
happens is you're walking now remember
when you watch Olympic walking and the
television you notice the rules are you
have too few heels down first and that's
the way normal walking is so normally
when you walk you put your heel down you
go into mid phase and you push off on
your left leg now your right leg you
have to bend your hip you have to bend
your knee and you have to what we call
dorsiflex or pick up your foot to get
your right leg from behind you to in
front of you so if you can't bend
you have to swing your leg out we call
this circum ducting your hip and
somebody can't bend the knee they have
to walk like this if they can't pick up
our dorsiflex their foot they will hyper
flex their hip and they'll have what's
called the step educate they'll walk
like that alright so as you see people
walk it's we call heel midphase push off
and here you're in what's called stance
phase so you're bearing your weight on
your left leg you shift your weight to
the left side you flex your hip flex
your knee and dorsiflex your foot swing
your right leg out put your heel down
here shift your weight over that a right
side follow-through and continue to do
that on a continuous basis and with
normal walking you should be walking
with a gait from about two to three
inches wide the length of your foots
about fifteen inches on your length of
your stride and you should be walking
with your hands moving and not looking
down and your body should be helped
should be kept fairly stable as you're
walking so here if I have a pointer here
so here's heel down mid phase push off
bending the knee and picking up the foot
very very important so this is a normal
gait and it's important to teach
clinicians about a normal gait so they
can identify when there are problems
affecting your gait so some of the
common problems that affect your gait
again I pointed out already a normal
stride is two to three inches wide and
15 inches long a normal step as we're
watching somebody walk we want to see if
they leave their foot flat on the ground
for as long as possible that they walk
in a relative straight line or shift
from side to side that they lean towards
one side when walking so they look at
the ground when they're walking if
people don't feel their feet very often
have nerve disease in their feet they'll
vary often have what's called a
searching gait look at the ground and
search as they walk a very common gait
patent in older people particularly with
cognitive problems is a so called
cautious gate or gate with fear when
falling so I mentioned a little bit
earlier that normally you have about
half
time when you're walking you're in
what's called stance phase and about 40
percent of the time you're in what's
called swing phase so your right foot is
is moving up and we call that swing
phase if you're very very afraid of
falling you don't want to be in swing
phase so you'll do the following now
living in New England and living through
winters like we just left to get down
here we're very used to have a driveway
which is covered with ice okay so when
you step on a driveway a couple with ice
you usually do the following you put
your feet wide apart you dump down a
little bit and you walk like this you
don't pick up your feet as your mother
would say okay but that's a cautious
skate pad so a cautious gait patent
people don't want to be in swing phase
they want their feet to be on the ground
all the time so they'll walk like this
so that's a fear of falling or a
cautious gait type of pattern that we
frequently see what are other things
it'll happen I've already mentioned this
if I can't bend my knee
then I'll sir conduct my hip like this
okay if I can't pick up my foot I will
have a what's called the savage gait the
passcode the guards at Buckingham Palace
the hyper flexion of the hip if I'm
watching the Patriots game last night
and add a few too many beers my gout
might be acting up so I may come in and
walk like this so what I'm doing now is
I'm spending less time on one leg than I
am on the other I'm spending less time
on my left leg that I am on my right leg
if I want to charge you a large
consultation fee I'll call that an
intelligent gait if I want to
communicate with you I'll call the limp
and it's all the same thing okay but
it's important thing to recognize that
because in fact if I have a bad hip so
my left hip is a problem I made you okay
walking and when I turn if I turn to the
right I'm turning on my good hip I'm
fine
okay but now if I'm trying to do the
same thing if I'm walking and I want to
turn on my left hip I'm now bearing all
my weight on my painful limb it's a good
way of falling okay it's trying to turn
on a painful leg so we do worry about
people that limp and we'll give them a
number one we'll try to find out what's
causing it and we'll try to deal with
that and then we'll try to deal with
fix it we may deal it with an assistive
device like a cane or we may use other
things to deal with that so this is a
person can pick up their foot
they'll have what's called a step
educate and if they have a painful leg
they'll be spending less time on that
leg and so they'll call the limp if they
this is the circum ducted gait because
somebody can't bend their knee okay so
but the key step in walking the key
issue in walking is balance so when we
want to assess balance nowadays I use a
very simple test it's called a force age
balance test so the four stages are I'll
have the patient's stand with both feet
together without an assistive device and
I'll do that for 10 seconds then I'll
have the patient take their right toe
big toe put it on the instep of their
left foot and do that for 10 seconds if
they can do that I'll have them do a so
called tandem gait which is one foot in
front of the other do that for 10
seconds if they can do that while I'm
stand on one foot for 10 seconds so
those are the four step balance tests we
stop the test when someone's having
probably we're standing right next to
the person but make sure they don't fall
over and patients who can't hold the
tandem stands for ten seconds have
increased fall risk but it's a very easy
way of identifying central balance
problems in people who are having
trouble falling it's a simple test to do
again put together toe on and to the
instep of one one foot in front of the
other and standing on one foot if we
have patients who have major balance
problems we have a variety of things
we'll do mainly exercises Tai Chi is
terrific I'm going to talk about the
kitchen exercise in a minute
building up endurance by walking or
swimming bracing is if needed an
appropriate help with a cane or a walker
as needed all right and balanced
training is best if it's done regularly
it's progressive and it's at least not
too boring it don't have initially be
fun but not too boring so in your
handouts I've given you a few of the
balance exercises that Mary developed
with Maggie gulled you need a very fancy
very expensive a piece of equipment for
this you need a kitchen sink and if you
have a counter on the kitchen
that's perfect because a way to do these
exercises is put your hand on the sink
so you can't fall when you do them and
then you do the exercises five steps to
the left five steps to the right
standing when one leg a variety of
different approaches but the major thing
is you're doing it putting your hands on
the kitchen counter
so you're not going to fall
so lastly very briefly I'll talk about
stairs so the problem with going up
stairs is when you have hip disease or
ankle disease because when you're going
up stairs you're flexing your hip and
you have to dorsiflex your foot to clear
the step when you're going down stairs
you are bearing weight on a bent knee
and that puts a lot of strain on the
knee particularly the so called
patellofemoral that's between the
kneecap and the knee bone the heart of
the knee joint so going up stairs we
worry about hip disease going down
stairs it's more out to be Neda's that's
going to give you trouble
and going down stairs as a problem about
75 percent of Falls on stairs occur when
people are going down stairs
particularly when they're holding
objects in their hands bifocal lenses
can be a problem because it sits at you
it's hard to identify how far the step
is from your foot when you have bifocal
or trifocal lenses and also if you have
nerve damage to your legs like patients
with diabetes often have you have
trouble sensing where your foot is and
that can also increase your problems so
we teach people if the laundry's in the
basement to put it put the laundry in a
plastic bag and throw it down the stairs
don't walk down the stairs holding a
laundry basket because that's a recipe
for disaster so where are we what's our
next step here I want to continue Yale's
groundbreaking research and preventing
Falls we're in the process of developing
a Mobility Center we're trying to Train
collisions and the skills needed to
assess and treat mobility problems and
this is all about low-tech work
you don't need MRI machines you don't
need ultrasound you need to observe the
patient you need to watch the patient
going through each step and determine
what is that factor that's limiting this
person where they're getting in our bed
getting off a chair walking etcetera you
need to determine the cause of that is
that a knee problem or a hip problem or
a back problem and then design a plan to
treat that immobility and to restore
independence thank you I'm gonna turn
this over to Brianne now
[Applause]
okay so as Raj mentioned before I have
done training in internal medicine and
geriatrics and in sleep medicine and so
I'm going to talk to you about my
passion today which is where these two
fields meet and so I want to start with
a little patient participation and I
want to ask you to raise your hand
if you care about sleep is sleep
important to you oh okay
wonderful all right it's I I think it's
potentially one of the most important
things but I'm a little bit biased so
here's what I want to talk about today I
hope to help you answer these three
questions by the end what is normal when
it comes to sleep when should you talk
to your doctor and what can you do to
improve your sleep and so in the bottom
corner here I have a picture that I
snapped when I was in Orlando at
Disneyworld a few months ago how to
sleep this is the noted lecture educator
in somnambulist goofy says guaranteed by
the by the time this lecture is over
you'll be fast asleep so my one goal
probably before any of answering any of
these questions for you is that you all
are not fast asleep by the end of this
ok so let's get started with what's
normal this is the National Sleep
Foundation recommendations about sleep
duration and so at the very end here
it's this pointer over here we have
adults and what you might notice here is
that young middle aged older adult the
sleep recommendations are actually the
same the recommendation is seven to
eight hours and where does that number
come from well it comes from studies
that have shown that older adults who
sleep seven to eight hours have better
cognition better physical and mental
health and report a better quality of
life and so I think what I want to
dispel is that myth that as you get
older you don't need as much sleep
because that's not actually true
so again keeping with that theme of
what's normal this is very well known to
a sleep physician this is a sleep
histogram so along the bottom you see
the hours of sleep during the night and
on the side we have stages of sleep so
up here you're gonna start your awake
that's W and then you're gonna go
through more deeper stages of sleep and
in the beginning what you might notice
here is that this is where your deep
sleep happens it's really in the
beginning of the night and after about
90 minutes you'll cycle up into your
first REM period REM is rapid eye
movement sleep that's your dream sleep
REM usually ends with an arousal that
you may or may not remember and then
you'll do it again you'll cycle through
these safe stages of sleep towards the
end of the night it's really more
lighter stages cycling with REM and so
that again the two things I want to
focus on here are deeper more
restorative sleep happens in the
beginning of the night and then the
other thing is that arousal ZAR normal
okay so as long as they're brief and you
can go back to sleep that's not a
problem
we expect that but sleep quality may
change and what I mean by that is as we
get older we do have less deep sleep so
arousal are more common so your sleep
quality may change but as I reviewed for
you in terms of sleep duration your
sleep need does not change alright so on
the subject again of what's normal I
want to talk about how the timing of
sleep changes with age
so here we have time again we're sort of
looking through the night and over here
we have melatonin level so melatonin is
a hormone your body makes naturally and
releases in the early evening and it's a
hormone that tells your body it's time
to go to sleep so in blue here we have
usual sleep phase and so these if you
have a usual sleep phase around 8
o'clock your melatonin increases so
maybe around 10:00 or 11:00 you're ready
for sleep but we know with age
you tend to have an earlier release of
melatonin and so what that means is
you'll go to bed earlier and you will
also wake up earlier
an early morning awakening may be
bothersome having to go to bed earlier
may be bothersome maybe you have to miss
out on certain activities but it's not
abnormal as long as you have a normal
sleep duration okay so when should you
talk to your doctor and I think the the
important takeaway point here is if you
have sleep disturbance that you feel is
impacting your daytime function but more
specifically if you have snoring or
pauses in your breathing that you might
notice or perhaps your bed partner
notices that can be a sign of sleep
apnea which is a primary sleep disorder
I'll talk a little bit more about on the
next slide if you have frequent
urination at night and so my rule of
thumb is urinating one to two times a
night is most likely to be normal but if
you're urinating more than three or four
times a night
that can actually be a sign of sleep
apnea and it's something you want to
speak with your physician about leg
discomforts
so this might be numbness tingling a
creepy crawly sensation that prevents
sleep that can indicate another sleep
disorder which is called restless leg
syndrome and you want to speak with your
physician about that acting out dreams
this might be something that you have
noted or remember or it might be
something that a bed partner has told
you about this is an indicator of a
primary sleep disorder called
REM behavior disorder and it's something
you want to talk to your physician about
and finally anxiety rumination mind
racing that prevents sleep is something
you should speak with a physician about
and so all of these symptoms may
indicate what we call a primary sleep
disorder and these are the the four
major sleep disorders obstructive sleep
apnea
dr. Cooney referred to when he was
talking about CPAP restless leg syndrome
rapid eye movement behavior disorder
that's the acting out dreams and
insomnia
so trouble falling asleep or trouble
staying asleep with mine
seeing anxiety etc all of these things
become more common as we age and all of
these things are things that we can fix
so what are the problems with sleeping
pills you are here with a panel of
geriatricians and you're going to hear
more in the next talk about the four ms2
of those big M's are mentation or your
mind your ability to think clearly and
mobility and of course dr. Cooney just
told you a lot about mobility well we
know that sleeping pills interfere with
those MS and so more specifically and
when I talk about sleeping pills
sometimes we call these the Z drugs so
zolpidem is the left one you might know
them as ambien or lunesta and sometimes
vendo benzodiazepines like valium or
ativan might be used for sleep why we
don't like them they are associated with
an increased risk of Falls and then of
course related to that hip fracture so
there goes your mobility they are
associated with increased driving
accidents use of these medications also
impair your ability to think clearly so
we know they increase risk of cognitive
impairment and a big one actually that
people often use to help them sleep as a
medication benadryl I'm sure you're all
familiar with that the reason we don't
like benadryl is because it actually is
anticholinergic which is a fancy way of
saying it impairs your ability to think
clearly and finally all of these
medications have been shown in multiple
studies to increase risk of death so you
can see this cartoon here the this old
or older fly is talking to the Grim
Reaper fly and saying oh well I've lived
a good long life of over 29 days so we
know there's a huge risk of death with
these medications okay so you can't take
those medications but what can you do
and so I've talked a little bit already
about primary sleep disorders but really
what I like to focus on and sort of the
the conceptual framework of my work is
talking about what about these things
these medication effects this is another
em you're going to hear about in the
next talk and behavioral factors how can
we think about these and older adults
and intervene on these things to help
with sleep and so I would be remiss if I
didn't mention Meryton Ettie in my own
work she's been a very important mentor
and really this framework comes out of
the groundbreaking work she's done with
Falls and dizziness so I'm borrowing
from her okay so I have done work
specifically on insomnia and found in
older people these specific things that
all independently increase your risk of
having insomnia depression these are
those primary sleep disorders I was
talking about certain medications too
much sleeping during the day many of
these are things we can fix similarly
I've looked at the symptom of daytime
sleepiness and found again multiple
factors independently associated with us
low physical activity depression sleep
apnea medications and inability
difficulty sleeping at night again these
are all things that we can we can fix
they're all potentially modifiable and
so that's what my work focus is on
medication effects this is something I
actually put in the handout for all of
you so I just want to highlight a few
the fact is medications can affect your
sleep in many different ways and so to
highlight a few daytime drowsiness I
already spoke about benadryl it impairs
your ability to think but it also makes
you drowsy during the day which can make
it hard to sleep at night benzos I
mentioned valium ativan can make you
sleepy during the day certain
medications might be activating which
might make it hard to sleep at night and
then interestingly there are certain
medications you might be taking that can
worsen or cause primary sleep disorders
like restless leg syndrome or REM
behavior disorder and finally you might
be taking a medication that's causing a
sleep disruptive symptom the most common
example I think of is there are certain
medications that cause cough the
you're coughing at night it's pretty
hard to sleep you're on a medication
like a water pill and you have to
urinate multiple times a night that
makes it hard to sleep so that's another
way that medications can affect your
sleep all right
psych Gabor's does anybody speak German
here no okay oh do you know what this
means
I'm alright so so sight Gabbar is sort
of literally time grabber so I'm going
to teach you now about queues that you
have in your everyday life that help you
maintain a normal sleep wake cycle the
first and most important psyche ever is
light you go out in the morning the
light hits your eye it goes to this
master clock on your brain and that
master clock sets off a bunch of
physiologic signals so tell you tell
your body it's time to be awakened alert
and then at the appropriate time that
it's now time to go to sleep but we also
know that there are so called non photic
non light related time grabbers and
these are things like having a normal
sleep wake cycle physical activity
social time and meals these are all cues
you can give your body to maintain a
normal sleep wake cycle sleep hygiene
again this is in your handout I'm gonna
highlight a few things here but these
are behaviors that you can do to improve
your sleep so the number one here avoid
caffeine nicotine and alcohol so
caffeine and nicotine can be very
activating they can make it hard to fall
asleep or stay asleep and alcohol people
often think of as a good way to
self-medicate and the fact is it can
help you fall asleep but as your body
starts to metabolize the alcohol it will
wake you up so you may fall asleep but
you will not stay asleep so that's why
we recommend avoiding it no naps or this
is my sort of addition brief and early
so brief means less than an hour an
early means that you have to avoid
napping in something that we call in the
sleep world The Forbidden Zone the
Forbidden Zone is 7:00 to 10:00 p.m.
you're watching TV you're on your couch
maybe you doze off that's not allowed
because then it makes it very hard for
you to go and fall asleep in your bed so
know if you're going to nap it's got to
be brief and it has to be outside of the
Forbidden Zone
and then finally stay active even if you
feel
many people might think I didn't sleep
well
so I'm not gonna go do that thing today
I'm not gonna go play golf I'm not gonna
go to the theater I'm not gonna go see
my friends that's the wrong reaction
because if you go and do that activity
you're more likely to fall asleep at the
appropriate time afterwards and that
helps you maintain a normal sleep wake
schedule and so I think this is one of
my final slides but cognitive behavioral
therapy for insomnia is something many
people don't know about and this is sort
of the ultimate behavioral therapy to
improve your sleep and I want to make
sure you all know about it it's a non
drug based method so as geriatricians we
like this we like to avoid medications
if we can and we focus on changing
behaviors that might have a negative
impact on your sleep or changing
misconceptions or negative thoughts
about your sleep this is highly
successful it has been studied
specifically in older adults and been
shown to be highly successful as I said
it's not a medication and believe it or
not this is the first-line therapy above
any sleeping pill this is the first-line
therapy for problems with insomnia or
problems initiating or maintaining sleep
in in my final slide I'll talk about my
next steps I think you know dr. Cooney
has mentioned he wants a Center for
mobility and my ultimate goal is to
really have a model that is specific for
aging and sleep problems to say what is
it that's different and unique about
older adults that we should be
considering when we think about sleep
problems but also what are those things
that we can change and I've tried to
highlight a few of those for you today
and so what does it mean for me well it
means I have to spend a lot of my time
building the evidence getting grants and
designing these interventions but it's
certainly a place where I would love
your input because ultimately this is
for you and I need to know whether you
all find these sorts of things helpful
so those are my neck
steps in terms of trying to help with
sleep-wake symptoms and older adults all
right hello James lang it's great to be
here and my job here is like unlike last
night is not to go into overtime and to
finish up and make sure that you know
take these three wonderful talks that
we've already heard and try to
demonstrate how how we can translate
this into actually improving patient
care directly improving patient care and
I think one way we're going to learn
about how we're how we can do this is
through an age-friendly health system
which affects how doctors nurses and
clinicians can deliver care so in the
next 12 minutes I'm hoping to answer
three questions what is an age-friendly
health system why do we need one and how
will it affect your care as a patient so
what is an age-friendly health system
has anyone in the room ever heard of an
age-friendly health system okay all
right
well age-friendly health system is
evidence-based care in four core health
areas which I think you already know
where they are and it's applied across
all settings of health care so what I'm
talking about is not just internal
medicine or Family Practice offices and
talking about surgical offices inpatient
medicine
I see use skilled nursing facilities all
settings of health care
and the phone work we're using for the
for the age-friendly health system is
called the 4m model and it's four things
it's it's what matters most which we've
heard a little bit about developing
patient priorities and learning about
what matters most to patients mobility
its screening for Falls and physical
functioning and older adults to make
sure that they're still able to do what
matters most to them
it's medications screening for high-risk
medications eliminating medications that
we don't need or don't want and if we do
need medications focusing on the ones
that emot-- the safest ones ones that we
accept and lastly is mentation that's
the fourth M this is screening for
things like depression dementia changes
in your ability of your memory and
importantly delirium
this waxing and waning state of mental
confusion that we see very frequently in
the hospital and in the setting of acute
medical illnesses this is very important
in the sense that is it's a huge barrier
to patients figuring out what they want
and their priorities it's a it's a risk
for Falls and it's a cause for for--why
many medications are given so the for MS
there's a fifth M which is multi
morbidity or multi complex multi
morbidity care which is multiple medical
conditions which I won't talk about but
the forum's
were not a these are not arbitrary at
all in fact they were very calculated
and developed through a long history of
data and experience and much of the
research performed to develop these for
MS was performed at Yale University and
within the section of geriatrics at Yale
so the first one what matters most is
what dr. Cooney is already spoken about
and it's the work of Meryton Ettie which
we know that following through on
patient priorities lowers
hospitalization and increases
satisfaction for patients we know that
using fewer medications and safer
medications prevents complications also
through dr. tena Dee's work we know that
maintaining function reduces Falls and
reduces time in the hospital I don't
think anybody wants to spend any more
time in the hospital than they need to
lastly also through the work at Yale
through Sharon and away at Yale
University
we know that identifying and managing
mood and memory problems prevents
confusion and complications again the
same complications we've been hammering
home today which is false loss of
mobility and hospitalization so the Age
Friendly health system it's a national
initiative currently right now there's
interventions in the for MS occurring at
a hundred and twenty seven sites across
the country so it's a big deal
dr. Gianetti is actually co-chair of the
Advisory Committee for the for the prot
the national project and as you can see
on this slide on this slide
oops on this slide we have key
foundations and organizations devoted to
innovative healthcare changes who are
supporting the project and providing
important leadership and administrative
support to make sure that it ensures the
success of the program
so let's move on to Connecticut we've
got the Yale New Haven health system
which maybe some of you in the room are
familiar with I think the take-home
point here is it's big it's very big
we have over 2,500 licensed beds in the
state and we do over 2.3 million
outpatient encounters I've got more than
24,000 employees so what you need to
take away from this is that any
intervention like the like the for Ms
with the Age Friendly health system has
the potential to have huge impact across
even just the state of Connecticut let's
take a look at Florida we have two sites
in Florida Moffitt Cancer Center in
Tampa and University of Florida Health
System in Gainesville um each of these
has a few sites at them but in general
you can see there is a there's a little
there's a little work to be done in
South Florida so I think what we'll talk
a little bit we'll have some time
afterwards to talk a little bit about
how we can do this but I think it's it's
something where there's an area of
growth here so why do we need why do we
need an age-friendly Health System so I
think there's two main reasons the first
reason is again patients are more
complex this slide shows the percent of
patients with more than six diagnoses
just like our mr. Smith and on the
bottom here you see that when you
compare the number of diagnoses with age
increasing from 65 to more than 85 you
see that the percent of patients with
more than six diagnoses rapidly
increases so this means
greater need for for talking about
patient priorities with competing
competing diagnosis more medications
focusing on mobility with with an
increasing number of diagnoses the
second reason is healthcare use
increases with age now we all know the
population above the age of 65 is
increasing it's 55 million now it's
going to continue to grow the
implication of this though is that we're
going to use more care and this slide
demonstrates that particularly with edie
visits sorry sorry um with edy visits
and it's hospital days hospital days you
can see that from age 65 to greater than
75 the rate of use of healthcare
increases it almost doubles so you're
gonna see a rapid increase as folks get
older so how will the age friendly
health system affect your care I think
it's time we went back to the case of
mr. Smith that we heard about a little
bit earlier and and go through what
might happen to him so let's say mr.
Smith came to the Yale emergency
department after a fall at home and
recently had a feeling of heart
fluttering while he's exercising it did
at the club gym you can see he's got at
least six six diagnoses including high
blood pressure arthritis and diabetes
and he's on several medications one or
two of which you might recognize as
being fairly high risk so mr. Smith gets
to the emergency department and you see
that he's got a low blood pressure here
and a fast pulse the doctor is concerned
about an abnormal heart rhythm and wants
to admit the patient to the hospital for
monitoring somewhat concerned that the
patient may actually have to have an
invasive heart procedure
possibly
this is a great opportunity to explore
patient priorities this is where we can
teach physicians to ask the right kinds
of questions to guide their care for
example have you talked with your
primary care doctor about what matters
most to you I understand that you
wouldn't want surgery
mr. Smith back didn't really want as his
hip surgery but would that change if
this would help you get back to the gym
so it's asking these kinds of questions
that focuses the care in the hospital
towards what mr. Smith would want and
may ultimately affect whether he gets
procedure or not and doing this at the
beginning of the admission makes a big
difference so now mr. Smith heads up to
the floor in the hospital this is
actually yale-new Haven Hospital Edie
so arrives on the unit and we screen him
for it delirium which is that waxing and
waning state of mental confusion the
nurse will evaluate him with a two item
screen for delirium asking him what are
the months of the year backwards what is
the day of the week if you're confused
this can be pretty tough questions
if he inches these incorrectly and the
screen is positive this will trigger a
delirium treatment protocol and as you
can see here this is an active area of
what we're doing with the age friendly
health system we're developing treatment
delirium treatment protocols and this is
just an example of the kinds of things
we'll do but I think to give you a sense
of the kinds of interventions that we're
looking at we'll look at doing things
like managing his sleep clustering care
during his sleep hours making sure it's
quiet because we know those kinds of
things can disrupt sleep and lead to
further delirium we'll look for pain
look for dehydration look for underlying
sources of infection and and check blood
sugars all these kinds of things that
will lead to underlying delirium and
lastly even though a patient may be
delirious or have some confusion it's
still important to get these patients up
and moving to make sure that they do not
lose their mobility
next a doctor on the floor will actually
screen mr. Smith for high-risk
medications okay so if we were so for
mr. Smith in this case he's taking some
benadryl over the counter which we all
know actually hopefully everybody knows
in this room when we walk out of here
that benadryl is not a medication we've
liked very much
it's an anticholinergic medication it's
it's been well shown to be associated
with confusion and Falls so we'll inform
mr. Smith that this is not a medication
we want them to use and get him off it
now we have losartan which is a nice
blood pressure medication but his blood
pressure was low and way and and it may
be very well justified for his high
blood pressure sometimes the risks of
medications outweigh the benefits and
this is just one of those situations so
he manned up actually having to stop
this medication even though it's
something that you know one of his
doctors may told him is good for him so
I think this is one other so what I also
want to show you is that behind the
scenes there's a lot of work that goes
into this so one of the things the Age
Friendly Health System is doing is is
helping us develop ways to track tools
to track and monitor high-risk
medications and this can involve a lot
of computer work a lot of boring
computer work but what happens is is we
develop filters in our electronic
medical record system that actually flag
high risk medications to anybody working
in the chart so that that won't when
someone looks in the chart and sees hey
they're on there on a medication they
shouldn't be on or it's a high risk
medication we know it's there and we can
address it so you may not see these
things as a patient but it's important
to know that they're they're going on in
the in the back room lastly on the unit
it's important to keep mr. Smith moving
okay as dr. Cooney talked about we're
gonna screen for fall risk we're gonna
do
clinical assessments to look for balance
and wall
we'll also use things like the Johns
Hopkins highest level of mobility scale
and other scales to help track mobility
while the patients in the hospital while
mr. Smithson in the hospital and and
make sure that he reaches certain goals
and gets back to the level of mobility
that he had before he came in so I think
I think there's three things I just want
to summarize at the end here
age-friendly Health System is an
evidence-based care model for older
adults that focuses on what matters most
secondly Yale geriatrics is a leader in
developing and implementing an
age-friendly health system and we will
continue to be and finally I think you
should demand that your health system
become age friendly and become a part of
this demonstration project and program
to help improve the care of older adults
so thank you very much
[Applause]
oh yeah that was uh that was outstanding
and really wonderful to have some very
very distinguished panelists here
discussing the science of Aging I'd like
to open the floor for questions and
we'll move the microphone around if so
be so you can sort our balance could
hear of course how do you get one okay
perfect
lay this gentleman here video I can go
just one question
among the many things you mentioned I
did not hear any mention whatsoever
about nutrition and its role in good
health for people as they age and I
think you hear your thoughts about that
we all had about 10 minutes apiece so we
could we couldn't cover all aspects one
of the most important aspects of
nutrition is its predictor of mortality
so when you're doing goals of care
discussions with elderly and with that
with particularly with family members or
with older patients the three major
predictors of mortality are poor
nutrition poor cognition and poor
function so as a weight loss attempt on
weight lost in six months clearly is
associated with increased mortality so
we agree that nutrition is very very
important we had a lot to cover and they
couldn't go through all the other things
yes sir
does taking a melatonin pill suppress
your natural body's production of
melatonin and what do you think about
the use of melatonin so that feels like
a question that's meant for me so this
is this is a subject I could talk a lot
about does it suppress your natural
melatonin release it can and in fact
sometimes we do that intentionally I
talked about advanced sleep phase and so
if we wanted to try and change your
sleep phase we could do that with
melatonin
if you experience jetlag you can use
melatonin to actually change your
sleep-wake rhythm
so yes melatonin can change that how do
I feel about melatonin well it's
certainly a pretty safe medication
especially in low doses I I think the
one thing I warn against is to keep
going up and up and up on the dose to
try and see if there's a response at
higher doses it can have side effects
particularly I think there's good
evidence to show that it can mess with
your blood sugar so if you're going to
use it there's really outside of REM
sleep behavior disorder which we use
melatonin for if you're trying to use it
for sleep it's it's pretty safe as long
as you maintain it at at doses below six
milligrams does that did I answer all
your questions do I recommend it yes I
think I think melatonin is definitely
one of the safest sleep medications that
you can take but what I worry about is
if you are feeling the need to take it
on a regular basis that maybe there are
some other things about your sleep we
should address when you're taking a
sleep medicine every day it doesn't work
so that the problem with taking it every
single day is it's not very effective
whatever that medicine is either
melatonin Thank You panelists so I
learned a lot I liked what you all said
about collaboration I think that's very
important especially about my
medications now who is going to pay for
my cardiologist to talk to my GP how
does that going to work into the
insurance system yeah we have to take
American medicine into the 21st century
it's about the 18th right now and that
we have to integrate things much better
a lot of systems are being developed
with better integration we actually have
we're starting to do something at Yale
which I think other people are doing as
well and what's called an e consult and
Medicare will actually pay for that so
your primary care physician can contact
your cardiologist about the use of about
your medications get a consult again via
email or via electronically and Medicare
will actually pay for that so there
there are some bright lights on the
horizon
but we're still a long way from a fully
integrated health system I just had one
more comment on that you know one of the
things that's changed over the last five
years is really electronic medical
records and and the community it's
improved the communication between
doctors and between doctors nurses nurse
practitioners especially specialists and
primary care doctors and the hospital as
well there's one med list a lot of times
so that actually really helps a lot we
can actually we can all reconcile the
same med list and and it and so
technology plays a big role in this what
one of your slides showed that in the
state of Florida there's only two
centers that are age-friendly both of
which have medical schools do we need a
medical school in Naples no I think this
is not something that's going to go away
this is a this is a a there's many many
other states that don't have kind of
folks working on Age Friendly health
system projects I actually think that
that it will it will get to South
Florida no problem even without a
medical school because I think the the
the kinds of interventions that that are
being introduced through this project
are cost effective and good for patient
care and when you hear those things it
will spread fast so so I think I think I
think it'll happen it's just gonna take
some time yes
you
is it it clearly is take all the
benadryl all the Tylenol PM in your
house and throw it out it's when you
take medications for dementia you use
what's called a cholinesterase inhibitor
eres FX long patch etc and benadryl does
just the opposite
so the benadryl is a sleep aid
it's a terrible sleep bed all right we
it took us about ten years to get it off
the formulary yanma Haven Hospital so
it's no longer used for sleep at Yale
New Haven Hospital it's really
problematic because it causes what's
called delirium or confusion if you have
any cognitive minor cognitive problems
so we really read it also affects your
you're urinating it affects it just has
a lot of bad side effects
so actually we recommend all the
patients that come to our clinic don't
take allergy pills unless you really
have to don't take any over the counter
sleep pills because most of them have
benadryl in them and don't take cold
pills they don't work anyway so so it's
really a bad drug for older people the
benadryl my house works pretty good
personally I not I'm not saying there's
an exception to every rule
and I'm not saying universally it kills
people but when you study the medication
it's bad effects greatly are overwhelm
it's good effects yes sir
I'd like to impose on you for two
questions first of all I find a lot of
times in the mornings if I'm at my desk
I get so sleepy but I'm not very
productive usually then after that I'll
take a nap no decent solution is that
okay
so napping is one of the things about
sleep medicine that's actually being
very actively studied and if I were to
summarize that I think what we know so
far is that napping is has it does have
a lot of benefits for your cognition and
for your ability to think clearly and
it's okay as long as you're getting a
relatively normal amount of sleep at
night so when we are worried about
napping is if it's part of a cycle of
sleeping too much because we know that's
bad for you but if you have a relatively
normal amount of sleep at night
and you're taking short naps that don't
otherwise interfere would that sleep
then it's it's fine
thank you my second question I have
restless leg syndrome how far ahead of
my bedtime should I take the medicine
for restless leg so you should probably
take it if you can determine the time
the symptoms usually come on then you
want to take the medication about an
hour before that so if you know your
symptoms sometimes people find them in
the early evening that's most common so
if you know your symptoms come on around
seven o'clock at night then you want to
take the medication at six thank you one
other question we can't answer
individual health questions we don't
know your health so we do answer general
questions but if you're asking me why
your back hurts I'm not going to do a
very good job of answering that all
right yes I have a question for dr.
Cooney could you talk a little bit about
clinical mobility assessment you know is
it your hips is that your knee is that
your back and what do you do when the
specialists meaning the orthopedist the
neurosurgeon the neurologist and the
pain management specialist can't agree
on what's driving what yeah it's a
little bit hard to say because it's not
a well-defined specialty of looking at
that probably if I was going to pick a
specialist on my picking arthritis dr.
rheumatologist but I happen to be but
also specialist in rehabilitation that
is physical medicine rehabilitation
sometimes called physiatrist first of
all they don't have a dog in the race so
they're they're not pushing their
particular procedure but I've spent a
long time working
multiple specialists and it's the best
thing to do is when we decide you need a
hip replacement then we send you the
orthopedic surgeon we don't send to the
orthopedic surgeon because you having
trouble walking we have to figure out
what it is it's not very complicated it
just requires your powers of
observations absolutely key and
sometimes physical therapists are very
good at that so I would say probably the
three that I would look at would be
physical therapists occupational
therapists specialists and
rehabilitation medicine physiatrist and
arthritis doctors probably have the best
broad spectrum of looking at that now
you'll find the auto surgeon is fabulous
at it so I'm not saying that but it is
it's a tough call
yes I've had that is this twerking okay
I had the distinct privilege of spending
my entire career in internal medicine
and tertiary care hospitals including
Grace New Haven Yale University Hospital
Southwestern Medical School in Dallas
and Vanderbilt University we had a
tradition that I loved we had all orders
and every decision going through one
person in the hospital that was the
intern now it's true that the intern
didn't know as much maybe isn't this
consulting physician nor that consulting
physician but it surely was a great
training experience for that intern but
also it it kept track of the complexity
of the patients that often occur on
those wards the often times our patients
would be like your elderly patient I'm
wondering if you've done a research
project that would possibly have a
similarity and because the elderly
people have oftentimes many conditions
and it would be so fascinating to me if
I can just joining answer that if this
analogy right the there have been
enormous numbers of studies that have
looked there have health care systems by
far the best systems have strong primary
care bases so the individual that should
be making final decisions should be your
primary care physician unfortunately
that doesn't work all that well it takes
a lot of work to do that but if you go
both inside this United States and
throughout the world the strongest most
effective systems have strong primary
care bases x-square I'm sorry
thank you dr. Lai you are encouraging us
to advocate for ourselves essentially to
encourage our doctors or choose a doctor
who is in favor of this age friendly
approach at what age do you think we
should encourage our doctors to assess
these different levels of do we do we
wait until we're limping or do we
establish a baseline for our mobility or
are we feeling blue or low or what you
know all the different aspects of the
four the four major aspects to set a
baseline or do we just so that we don't
have to wait until we're pulling up
blame let's say that's a great question
and I think that's a point you know
point well made is that you know these
kinds of interventions they're good for
all patients I mean they're not just
there they're particularly good for
older patients and they've been studied
in that in that age group but they're
actually good interventions for all
patients so it's it's actually not too
early to start you know evaluating you
know folks even and you know I'm you
know late 40s 50s I mean these are
things that that physicians should be
aware of and and screening for all along
they become more relevant as you get
into your you know sick early 60s 70s so
you know I think you know anything to
add with in our system again what's
called North East Medical Group which is
a foundation that that's run by our
health system we've actually made the
recommendations that cognitive testing
very simple cognitive testing a two
minute test should be done with
everybody 65 and older we also ask
physicians to assess and this is just
the questions ones ability to do what we
call activities of daily living that's
getting our bed by itself walking by
yourself to using a toilet by yourself
we suggest that be done on everybody 65
and older and we suggest a medication
review every year on people 65 and over
that's what we're doing in our system
it's not very time-consuming gives us a
good baseline and it's very important to
identify cognitive problems because if
you're giving someone 12 medications and
they have cognitive problems you have a
major issue in your sight if there's
such a thing as substitutes for sleep
because having a lot of problems that
cause me to not be able to get very much
sleep I'm finding that with our therapy
color flower of photography in
particular if I'm working with that
which is something that that I love that
causes things you'd be very happy that I
find that that gives me almost a
substitute for sleep that I am revived
and feel that I that it keeps me going
when I don't get very much sleep at all
well I don't know that it's a substitute
for sleep but what we know is that mood
and sleep are so tightly intertwined so
people who have trouble sleeping are
more likely to have mood problems people
who have mood problems are more likely
to have sleep problems so I think it's
absolutely true that if you are treating
one of those things you're likely to see
benefits in the other domain and
cognitive behavioral therapy that I
mentioned for insomnia people are
looking at that and looking at outcomes
for depression and finding out that
people who do cognitive behavioral
therapy for insomnia do have
improvements in their mood so I think
both I think your point is well-taken in
that those substitutes as you call them
it's it's often something that we try to
act on if we are concerned about sleep
problems I want to ask a slightly
different question because dr. Contreras
is one of the practicing physicians in
the practice here at Maureen's Parc is
with us today and I'm just anxious to
hear what his reaction to what he's
heard today is and I'm gonna hand him
the mic do you dare answer that
thank you for putting me on the spot
like this with regards to the question
that was just asked Medicare pays for an
annual wellness visit that started at
the age of 65 and the annual wellness
visit was designed with the help of
geriatricians and other primary care
physicians to identify some of the
issues that were raised today very
eloquently and this is paid for by
Medicare we encourage everybody starting
at 65 to get an annual wellness visit
primary care doctors know about it
it's a little bit challenging to
administer because it involves some
screenings cognition screenings gait
screenings nutrition and all the things
that were covered here today should be
done annually starting at age 65 because
that's when you want to try to pick up
issues and if it's done every year it's
a good way to check for changes that may
be taking place over time to identify
these interventions that are so
important to prevent progression so I
just wanted to reiterate you know
everything that's been spoken of we
encourage all of our patients here to
have an annual wellness visit we usually
do that in in conjunction with the so
called physical the annual wellness
visit is not a physical the Medicare
does not pay for physicals but it will
pay for this annual wellness visit but
we generally combine the visits together
to identify that that way we can keep a
record and identify people who were who
were changing in in progress
I have a pretty loud voice I think I
could handle it without the mic dr.
miner if you get her get on asleep CPAP
machine can you ever get off that is a
good question
I think in short most of the time the
answer is no and that's because we think
often of obesity as a major risk factor
for sleep apnea but it's actually just
one of the reasons that people have
sleep apnea
usually there are anatomic reasons that
they have a small airway they're more
likely to have their airway collapse
while they're sleeping and so that might
not be something that we can fix with
weight loss but what I would tell you is
that you can certainly go from a more
severe category of sleep apnea to a more
moderate or mild which allows you to
consider other treatments that don't
necessarily involve CPAP I think I have
a question for dr. Cooney but I'll leave
it all the other panelists as well so
I'm a vascular surgeon vascular
specialist and practiced in Naples of
this community wonderful community for
nearly 20 years and I've been privy to
much of the technological improvements
in our specialty that allow us to help
people walk with circulatory problems
but we've now transitioned a lot of our
operations from open surgical procedures
to minimally invasive so as probably a
lot of you know we do a lot of phenol
access procedures so long-winded
question but is that something I need to
be concerned about or should I you I
enjoyed your talk on mobility it cannot
contribute to some loss of mobility
postoperatively that we can we can
improve upon I if you can keep people
out of a hospital that's a very positive
thing so I think if you can do the
procedure as an outpatient without an
extensive time of bed rest without
hospitalization we think that's very
positive
I think the one thing to be aware though
before you're doing any procedure on an
older person you should know something
up up up about their cognition because
if you have somebody who has memory loss
that a lot of people may not realize and
they get their anesthesia that they need
or they're just in the foreign
environment of a post acute care unit of
PACU they can get delirious and that's a
big problem so I think doing it as an
outpatient with the more minimal
procedure is a great idea but I think
any older patient that you're
contemplating do surgery on when I see
someone we're thinking about doing a hip
or knee replacement it's much more
important to know their cognition and to
know anything else about that person
because if they have cognitive problems
their likelihood of them becoming
delirious around a procedure is very
high that's a big problem
[Music]
for more questions that
we recommend seven to eight hours is
getting nine hours is that benign or you
lose something so I won't pull this
slide up but there the the National
Sleep Foundation recommendations are
seven to eight hours but they recognize
on others on either side that nine hours
may be appropriate or five to six hours
may be appropriate so we know that there
are certain people there there are
individual differences so you know right
smack in the middle is seven to eight
but just on either side may also be
appropriate and so I guess I would ask
you to think also about the quality and
not just the quantity of your sleep any
more questions for the audience
excellent okay well round of applause
for our very fantastic balance this
afternoon
we also like to thank Maureen's Park and
the L Club of Southwest Florida
including mr. Hansen and mr. Horton for
their or for organizing this event along
with Yale University School of Medicine
thank you very much
you